so game theory is as the science of
strategic thinking the idea here is that
anytime that you're interacting with
another person who has their own
interests and is trying to achieve their
own ends they are trying to do the best
they can given what they want you're
trying to do the best you can given what
you want and so you're interacting in a
strategic situation one of you is trying
to achieve what what you want the other
is trying to achieve what they want game
theory is a mathematical theory that
attempts to make sense of how it is that
people interact in these strategic
situations it was originally developed
in economics in order to try and
understand economic behavior like why
people buy certain things or why they're
willing to work for certain wages but
later on it was expanded and applied to
a variety of different situations
including biology international
relations and even interpersonal
relations like friendship and parenting
and family relations so one of the big
problems that parents constantly
confront when they're raising two kids
is that the kids will sometimes compete
with one another in order to get out of
doing family chores leaving them to the
siblings but the problem is of course
the other kid the sibling or friend is
going to figure that out too and so
we'll try and shirk as well in the end
the parents left with a messy room the
kids are upset with one another and
nobody's happy one of the things that
game theory has tried to deal with are
these types of situations they're
sometimes called social dilemmas or
prisoners dilemmas these are situations
where each individual has a private
incentive to do something but when both
of them follow their private incentives
the group or the two siblings are worse
off than if they had ignored their
private incentives and just work
together one of the seminal discoveries
in this area is that by teaching kids or
countries or anyone for that matter that
you can break up that interaction into a
bunch of little small interactions where
you can cooperate with the other one but
just on condition that the other one
cooperated with you before you can
change a bad social dilemma into a
positive interaction this was put to its
biggest
use in the during the Cold War Reagan
and Gorbachev negotiated the START
treaty with one another and one of the
big problems that they had is how can
you be sure that while you're
eliminating nuclear weapons your
adversary is also eliminating nuclear
weapons so rather than saying we're just
going to get rid of some large
percentage of our nuclear weapons and
hope that that the USSR would do so as
well they broke up the interaction into
a bunch of little tiny ones
so the USSR would eliminate just a few
nuclear weapons then the US would
eliminate just a few nuclear weapons
they would check and then they would go
on to the next stage and then each would
eliminate a few more and they'd go on to
the next stage this process of taking a
big interaction and breaking it down
into little small parts is one that we
can use all over our lives including in
parenting
so rather than mom or dad coming into
the room and saying to the kids clean up
the room and then leaving mom and dad
can come up and say here's the deal each
of you take turns putting away one toy
and you make a deal with one another if
you put away your toy I'll put away mine
and by taking the big interaction
cleaning up the room and breaking it
into a series of small interactions you
make it feasible for the kids to
cooperate with one another in a way that
wasn't really possible before when you
just left them with one big chore where
they had to decide whether they wanted
to do it or not one popular proposal
that's often occurred in tax debates is
that we ought to lower our corporate tax
rate in order to encourage companies
that have located their assets offshore
to bring them back into the United
States the idea here is that if we lower
our corporate tax rate to be competitive
with other countries then corporations
don't have a reason to move their money
offshore the danger here is that if we
lower our corporate tax rate then
another country might lower their
corporate tax rate and as a result we
end up in a race to the bottom each
country lowering their rate to compete
with the other one until eventually we
end up with a corporate tax rate of zero
or near zero or at least so low that we
barely make any money if only we could
get together with all the other
countries and agree to fix our corporate
tax rate at a kind of uniform number and
not to compete with one another all
countries would be better off no come
would have an incentive to move their
assets offshore but countries wouldn't
lose out on the income from the higher
corporate tax rate the difficulty here
of course is that international
cooperation is a hard thing to do
the Nobel prize-winning economist Elinor
Ostrom did a history of social dilemmas
and prisoners dilemmas and found that
there are lots of different strategies
that people have used over time in order
to prevent races to the bottom and
competitions of this form the
traditional economic story about social
dilemmas and prisoners dilemmas has been
there are kind of two solutions one
solution is the completely libertarian
solution where you just privatize
everything and you make everyone owns
own everything the other is to have a
single government that controls
everything the problem International
Relations is neither of these are really
feasible there's no way that we can
privatize individual corporations and
give their ownership to individual
countries but nor can we have a world
government that specifies what the
corporate tax rate in every single
country would be what Elinor Ostrom
found in her historic study of these
types of social dilemmas was that over
history people have found very
sophisticated strategies that involve
complicated checks and balances
agreements and structures that allow
them to solve these problems without
going to either extreme so we suggest
that there might be ways of modifying
these individual small institutional
arrangements in order to try and develop
a series of international agreements
where individual countries could have
mechanisms to punish those countries who
lower their corporate tax rate so we
don't have to just trust so that other
countries are going to follow through on
their promises